There is only one war that matters and It is here
Shame!
Game of throne's fans
That's what I'm talking about
It's overwhelming, but in the best possible way
A place where people can really demonstrate their passion
King of the north!
Action!
Last scene, here it is
Alright, here we go
To see the joy it brings so many people faces.
It's amazing, you know?
If they didn't watch, if they weren't fans...
...we would have nothing to do so, it's our way of kind of saying thank you
If you ended up on the iron throne what would be the first law you would pass
That women could be knights
How about, uhm...
...maesters have to clean up their own stinking bed
If, there are one character (Hodor) you wish haven't been killed, who would it be?
I just really loved working with...
...Jack Gleeson so much that I have to say Joffrey...
...He was so fun to hate
It's a show made by grown-ups for grown-ups, and we take chances
This season, especially, everyone's kind of congregating to team up against the oncoming threat
You can feel the momentum building.  Lots of stuff coming to a head
Alliances are being forged, alliances are being broken...
...It's all picking up
It's only gonna get bigger and better